when Lela joined me it was the first
time that I felt relief as an
entrepreneur where I felt like not only
does this person have this but they are
doing it better than me earlier
entrepreneurs and some of the smaller
companies that we work with like there's
a belief set of like no one can do it as
well as me and I think when you pay PE
really poorly and you attract poort
Talent into bad brand that probably is
true but the better you treat people the
more you attract A- Lev Talent the more
it's actually like they will do it
better than you and then you're more
like just Eng gratiate towards them like
I'm just very grateful that you still
want to work here and it kind of shifts
the power Dynamic to much more
collaborative that's all been her this
is not my wheelhouse Lila is the reason
that all the companies that we have have
scaled they're the reason that we've
been able to you know grow a lot of
companies has been her it's been the
soft tff and she just gets how people
take very well